it's interesting when you ride something
and you don't feel it until years later
when you can get the songwriter
to lose emotional control that's when
you're doing your job brother
kelly clarkson is back as a coach on
season 20 of the voice
and during monday's knockout round the
whole thing had her feeling emotional
i feel like i'm nailing it the talk show
host who had pal kelsey ballerini
sitting in with her team over the last
few weeks while she was out sick during
the battle rounds
returned just in time to pair up team
kelly singers riley modig
and corey ward and corey well
he made a risky song choice singing one
of kelly's tracks
already gone
[Music]
yeah during rehearsals for corey's
performance of the single from kelly's
2009 album
all i ever wanted season 20 mega mentor
snoop dogg
said he had chills one thing about my
emotions
i held my tear right here and pushed it
back up
and kelly she was brought to tears
thinking about the significance of those
lyrics
more than a decade later when i wrote
already gone
i was going through something that i
thought it's okay you don't we don't
always have to it doesn't have to work
out
and hearing him sing that to me in my
life now
are you like smacking me in the face
with my message
kelly filed for divorce from husband
brandon blackstock
last june after seven years of marriage
the exes share two children together
six-year-old daughter river rose and a
five-year-old son
remington alexander and earlier this
year
kelly told et that songwriting has been
therapeutic
during their split i have this record
that we're working on that
is is really great and it's very honest
it's just there's just like a lot of
there's a lot of questions that i just
have to answer before releasing it
for myself um you know
and and whether that be business wise or
personally or whatever but um
it's whatever happens though
it is such a gift like i don't know how
anybody i'll just be real with you goes
through
grief like divorce any kind of grief any
kind of loss
without having an outlet but back to the
voice
when corey took the stage he knocked
kel's song
out of the park i literally was like
well he just
killed my song in front of me like i was
like that's maybe
how that was supposed to sound the
coaches were also wowed by riley's
performance of kings of leon's you
[Music]
[Music]
somebody
and that left kelly with a tough call
but ultimately she chose corey as the
winner of the knockout
this story has a happy ending though not
one
not two but all three of kelly's fellow
coaches
blake shelton john legend and nick jonas
hit their buttons to try to steal
riley for their team and the 18 year old
powerhouse singer
she went with team legend i had to steal
riley she's young but she's got such
maturity in her voice and flavor she had
to come to team legend